she was kind of saying that she knows
who she is and she's 47 years old and
she doesn't want to keep growing
but that she wants to keep evolving I'm
so in love with this person without
knowing them you know what she's saying
I don't want to judge myself the Nuance
of evolving versus growth is when you
are in this game of growth if you watch
the people that are most obsessed with
it they're over judging themselves
they're subtly beating themselves up
like I need to be better I'm not good at
this I think what she's saying quick hot
take on hearing that because it really
hit me in my chest because I'm very
similar is I don't want to beat myself
up so you've spoken a lot about the
importance of self-awareness yes
um and you're like knowing your own
strengths and weaknesses so when you
were transitioning out of you know your
dad's wine business yes how did you
identify the skills and passions
um
that you wanted to pursue as an
entrepreneur I um there was a level of
like self-awareness but also passion
right and I talked about passion a lot
in my early career and it was because of
this when I
was leaving my dad's business it was
mainly because my brother AJ was
graduating from college and I knew that
I wanted to do a business with him and
it was also because I was in a family
business
and for all the people that are watching
or listening family businesses worked
very different they work like the
following I mean immigrant family
businesses like the one I was part of
which was
you don't get paid a lot
and you only get to own the business
when the old man or the old woman die so
I was starting to have these combos with
my dad I was like Dad I'm 34 now like
I'm starting to be a big boy
um and hey by the way I've helped build
your business from a four to a 70
million dollar business I need to go do
something I think for myself kind of
thing and so
I knew that I was getting close to that
transition
AJ was graduating in like six months to
a year and I was a crap so I got a pick
right and back to your question on
self-awareness I I said to myself what
do I like and what am I good at
and that pointed to marketing I built my
dad's business not only because I knew
wine or you know and I educated myself
very real in that yeah it was because I
did a website in 96. I did email
marketing in 97. I did Google AdWords in
2001 or two when when nobody was doing
these things they all worked
and at this point when I was
transitioning I did a YouTube show that
was crushing I was one of the first
people to have a million followers on
Twitter and I was like hey I'm good at
this and I like it right when I sold
lemonade I literally sold lemonade as a
kid mainly because I wanted to make the
sign
hey you know like it's you know but I
didn't realize I didn't I didn't realize
that at the time right but this back to
self-awareness I was like oh baseball
card shows I loved selling baseball
cards but figuring out different ways to
sell them was cool right the dollar rack
the spin the wheel the nine dollar boxes
so I realized I was a marketer that was
the self-awareness I realized I liked it
because I could have done a wine thing
because I knew wine really well but I
knew I liked marketing more than Wine
even though I liked wine and so I I
think it was just
being really aware and willing
to think of yourself in a different way
I'd never this is true now I had never
thought of myself as a marketer
prior to the year before I started this
company I thought of myself as a
businessman right I thought of myself as
a Salesman but I never thought of myself
as an advertising person I was just
doing what I thought would sell wine and
then I re-looked at myself through the
lens of self-awareness and passion
because I had a life decision to make so
that's how I got there
you know with the self-awareness and
passion what fears came up when knowing
that you were going to be an
entrepreneur and second half of that
question is what advice would you give
to entrepreneurs who are struggling with
similar concerns this is where I hate
that the uniqueness of my life isn't a
great answer but I can give you an
answer as someone who's talked to a
drillion people okay
Mott and here's where I'm going with
that I was such a poor student as a
child I was after about fourth grade not
as good at sports as like the best
people in sports I have good hand eye
coordination I was a scrapper but I had
and I was selling stuff my whole life
which meant I got a ton of no's yeah
that by the time I got to a place of
like running my dad's business or then
starting my own businesses
I wasn't scared of anything right did
you feel like you had nothing to lose
it was even better than that I didn't
care if I lost it wasn't that I didn't
have anything to lose it was that I
didn't care if I lost I cared if I
didn't try like it was like I often use
this analogy of like you know how in the
summer lightning bugs go to that like
blue light and like
they almost like I always think like
they know that they're gonna get killed
if they go to the light but they can't
help it they're like they're just going
to the light yeah that's how
entrepreneurship is for me like right I
don't have another gear so what I would
tell everybody is fall in love with
losing what I would tell parents
actually the people I really want to
talk on this one is parents the reason
eighth place trophies was a misstep
was we what we were teaching kids was
losing we were demonizing it we were
saying to them losing is bad so nobody
should lose
and what happened was the younger the
young gen Z generation the young
Millennial gen Z generation
was really unfortunately not everyone
there's millions of parents that
parented differently but by and large
especially in First World countries a
lot of people today the age 18 to 32
grew up in a parenting model that
believed in eighth place trophies that
believed in delusion self-esteem
building because I think self-esteem
building is the best but I think it has
to be grounded in practicality right
like right if you're a kid inflated it
can't right yeah like if your kid
doesn't have a musical bone in their
body
she loves Beyonce it's probably a bad
idea to tell her she could be Beyonce
too right but we lived through that
right we're starting to change because I
think we're seeing the ramifications I
would argue a lot of things that are
most dangerous about society today is
far more grounded in some of the
theories of modern parenting than it is
grounded in social media and I think we
have to start taking on accountability
so what I would tell everybody is the
following what were my fears none I've
been losing all my life in school in
sports in like business like that I was
prepared to lose again most people
aren't prepared to lose again most
people the reason so many Ivy League
school kids struggle as operators is
they aren't accustomed to losing when I
was an investor I realized oh wait a
minute
and I'll tell you it's really funny back
to some of the movies and some of the
stuff I found that kids that weren't
popular but were ivy league kids did
better as entrepreneurs right than the
kind of the lacks Superstar the good
looking guy who went to pet like they
just had too much
winning right and we're scared of losing
and then the problem with the business
is
there's no judge and jury it's just the
market right there's no teacher there's
no family relationships it's just the
Merit of the business so I would say I
didn't have fear but I would say to
answer your question in a way that I
hope brings value for the parents that
are listening right now the quicker you
teach your children that losing is not
only bad but weirdly kind of cool like
I'm very depressed right now because the
Knicks have lost the last two games okay
I didn't want to bring it up yeah thank
you so I flew home late lately last
night after the game
and like I'm sad but secretly I kind of
like it because I like the pain as a
like it's part of me and I think more
children more humans need to learn how
to be able to deal with adversity and
losing it'll make them happier you
probably know this um wait there's this
clip going around on the internet right
now and I I don't know the player's name
but the guy who is sitting having the
conversation with what's that
yeah exactly where he the guy asked him
you know did he fail this season
oh my god do you get the promotion every
year no right so every year you work as
a failure yes or no no every year you
work you work towards something two
years ago it's not a failure it's steps
to success and he goes on a very similar
tangent to say that you know no he
didn't fail this season did he get the
wins that he wanted no but it makes him
want to work harder and he has more
goals and you know he basically turned
around on the guy and said you know did
you get a promotion this year was and
the guy's like no he's like what was
your year of failure and the guy's like
no he's like okay well it's all about
like perspective in terms of
um you know what you're okay
um in terms of so many decisions to be
made in these settings oh yeah um
but yeah I mean well that's why Sports
is the best You Can't Hide right you
know people hide in everything else even
entrepreneurship I love entrepreneurship
because it's the closest
but you can still hide I have a an
acquaintance who in their profile it
says three under Instagram three time
exiting entrepreneur looks fancy
in reality because I know the situation
all three companies were a disaster
really yeah all of the exits were M A on
a penny on the dollar one was an
accu-hire okay and one was bought after
an obnoxious amount of funding for four
cents on the dollar
so but in in giannis's game You Can't
Hide no like the Knicks lost last night
that's it and this is why I've always
loved Sports the Merit an Academy Award
was a political decision behind the
scenes by a group of people
so everything else besides Sports in a
lot of ways is merit-based and that's
why I've always loved it business is
close but to your point I love that
Giannis did that because there's so many
comps to it like right now A lot of
people are realizing what athletes are
dealing with because now everyone's
putting themselves out there and they're
getting commented about everything about
everything about everything right and
that's what athletes have always had to
deal with one bad night and everyone's
got all sorts of things to say every one
of us in this room right now including
these two lovely ladies who are
dominating at their craft we have bad
days yeah you know and but it's hidden
right
you know it's a very interesting human
psychology conversation I love that that
Viral clip is going because I hope it
helps people speaking of the like the
viral or like the sorry the the
Mystic aspect of sportsmanship
um this is a random side note but I
really feel like there's a
a new kind of way for fans to interact
and have ownership with with like their
teams through like this web 3 type of
and I've been I've got to like hang out
with Ray Lewis and go check out his new
facility in
um Cleveland yep and I feel like if you
guys haven't chatted maybe you should
yes I've spoken to Ray I know how
entrepreneurial is we share a great
friend Reid Bergman who works for me
actually and I'm super aware and that's
right like the best part of web3 that is
yet to be realized is the Smart
contracts right the connection Point
there's still a lot of clarity we need
from the US government and the world on
what to do with all this stuff right but
with AI coming and us having to prove
Providence like by the way we're doing
an interview right now everything we're
saying is being recorded and that used
to be like the truth now we have deep
fake videos coming out right somebody
could literally take this video of us
and change the things we're saying like
the world's about to go through real
Revolution and I do think that the
blockchain and web 3 is going to be a
actually good contributor to it and I
think I think to your point like the
relationship graph of everything right
is about to happen I think about like
the um Grateful Dead and fish and those
bands that like people traveled with
yeah like what if those people in the
60s had an nft that could like go with
like so many cool things instead of just
collecting ticket stubs or photos so I'm
excited about the future that's cool
okay all right so you're really known
for your grind you're a consistent day
after day how do you kind of keep the
intensity and the focus up specifically
in the moments of like setbacks and
hardships
by not having success especially
Financial or notoriety validate anything
in my life
oh you like that one wow
no this this is some this is the biggest
thing that people don't know about me
like like I always get scared when
people are like you're known for the
grind and the hustle because I know that
there's a parallel to like burnout and
like I'm not even close to any of those
things because I have incredible
enjoyment in what I do and I don't do it
for the notoriety or the money and more
importantly and you've gotten to know me
through these years
it's just not my validation
I I am much more Associated to being
nice
and people knowing that to be true than
I am to how many followers I have or how
much money I have that is like honestly
if there is one takeaway from this
entire video today I hope people
listening at home can understand that
their validation it does not need to be
through their financial successes and
work commitments the reason like you
know like the people in my achievement
yeah the people that are super closest
to me my family and like the closest
friends that go into family zones they
all know the truth which is like I'm
crazy chill I'm hyper when I communicate
like I have high energy like I'm you're
also passionate yeah I'm happy right
I'm happy because of my Simplicity which
seems really crazy I get it because I am
an entrepreneur and because I do have a
lot of things going on but the thing
that I think works for me and I see it
in others but to your point
the majority of my contemporaries are
very different than I am
they are unfortunately in my opinion
because I worry about them too wrapped
up in achievement money status I mean
the thing that you know this has been
lately on my mind
maybe because I was in Miami for F1 and
I watched it play out again
people are heartbroken when they don't
get invited to the good party yeah
they're like they're like crushed when
they have to wait in line and they don't
have like like people wearing all the
bracelets like and I'm like man high
school plays forever yeah I'm like these
people are some of the most successful
attractive financially successful status
you know I know a lot of these people
like have good families have like great
children like and they are like blowing
a gasket or just I can see the upsetness
in their face because they weren't
invited to Carbone Beach right and
they're like I love Jeff but like like
it's gonna be okay yeah like and so and
social media has Amplified that but it
hasn't changed that I hate when people
are like we gotta blame social do we
because my Daddy's Liquor Store was not
far from a town called Short Hills New
Jersey and I watched all those people in
Short Hills New Jersey when somebody got
a new Mercedes they needed to get a new
Mercedes right when somebody came into
my I watched people my whole life come
in buy a case of Opus One and watch the
next customer waiting and hear it
because they know that person and buy
two cases of Opus right like it's been a
flex show for life right and you know
and Fashions become such a big bigger
part of our life and so what people what
brands people are wearing in this and
that and so I'm really glad we're
touching on this and I do think
especially knowing how epic your
audience is I think this is going to
help some people
like like how how am I handling it all
yeah because if it all went away
tomorrow I'd be just fine I don't need
to take another selfie I don't need to
make another dollar I was super back to
like I got fortunate because I'll say
this as well for everyone who's
listening the greatest thing that ever
happened in my life was I grew up with
very little I was born in the Soviet
Union I came here when I was little but
I was happy
and I was happy every day because I have
an iconic all-time great mom
and you don't need those things to be
happy and so I was born and lived in a
way where I knew that that wasn't a
direct correlation right A lot of people
my children included will never know is
it the money or is it not right and so
you get caught up in this thing of like
okay like any time I say like money
doesn't buy happiness the comments are
littered with easy for you to say and
I'm like you don't know me like that you
don't know me
like easy for me to say because I've
actually lived it not because I have
money now that oh by the way I earned
and so I think for a lot of people they
they don't know and I think you know one
of the great things of living a life
where you go coast to coast in your
journey is you know right you know that
they're like I have unlimited people
that have hundreds of millions of
dollars to their name and are deeply
interested we know this we're very
fortunate we run in circles we've been
in places around the world and you see
and it's really sad and I think it has
everything to do and I really appreciate
both of you reacting the way you did
it's the one what you know it's the one
thing I need to make sure I communicate
before I die that if you are not and by
the way it's the same way I think about
beauty
one of the biggest things I worry about
is what parents affirm to children on
their way up if you are a human and the
first 20 years of your life your parents
your relatives and your classmates
continue to give you validation because
you are attractive what do you think is
going to happen when you're 50 and
father time is starting to play its game
of course you're going to go through
some feelings of course you're going to
probably over worry about that you were
taught that that's your validation but
that's the same thing about sports you
know many people are great at Sports and
then don't make it into the professional
realm and then really struggle with the
transition because all their validation
is the same way I think about Straight
A's right my biggest problem with school
is if you keep telling a kid you're
great you're great you're great because
you're getting A's the problem is the
world doesn't work on a B's and C's
right and so you have a lot of people in
their 20s to 30s who struggle in life
transition because all they've ever
known is how to figure out a school
system right that's what the world told
them they were good for and so I think
as parents we have to be careful of what
we validate which is why what my mom did
for me is what I am passionate about
doing for not only my children but the
world which is like let's validate on
how we treat each other right my mom
wants lost her mind as if I won the
Nobel Peace Prize because I oh I can I'm
visualizing right now I was less than 10
years old I opened the door for an
elderly woman to walk into a McDonald's
in North Plainfield New Jersey
you would have thought that I cured
cancer
my mom spent the next two hours telling
me why that was so great but that is the
thing why you're the best she called me
golden hearted my whole life of course I
answered my question earlier about what
I care about it's what she instilled I
want to be known for how I treat people
speaking of beauty I was at a dinner
last night and there was an emotion
emotional intelligence coach there who
was moderating a conversation and it was
a really beautiful conversation and I'm
going to touch on this in a second as
well on a different part of the the
combo but she mentioned that when she
was growing up her mother did not allow
her to wear makeup until she was 18 and
she was obviously really annoyed by that
as a teenager but it was really to
instill the fact that she wanted her
daughter to be comfortable in her own
skin and I feel like that is another you
know version of when I heard that I was
like oh my gosh I'm so like on the money
as I like started to think about how I
you know how I behave in front of my
kids you know the types of routines I
show them and you know the way I speak
to them about their self-confidence and
you know it's just it's just a I feel
like these moments don't we don't talk
about them that often
um but they're really quite important
and they end up shaping us from like a
you know a whole identity standpoint in
a in a way that
I couldn't believe in it more right
meaning you may or may not have to go to
aggressive tactics or what may seem like
an aggressive tactic
but instilling
the right the right things is everything
and so like for example and you know
this because you're very educated in
this
there's a lot of variants to Beauty
versus Health and Wellness
so like there's the concept of like lip
filler
is very different than eating clean
so I think that's going to be a big
topic of conversation over the next 20
years as we get more advanced than what
you just talked about there are certain
things that are artificial enhancements
to to
live up to the current state of beauty
right right look at your life I look at
you and I can see visually huh she grew
up in an era where girls that look like
her were the standard and now that she's
older her look is more the standard and
standards change right right what is
considered beautiful changes
so there are differences of like are you
in a life cycle where the way you look
is considered the standard of the day or
is it not and then do you do something
about it to keep up with the Joneses all
right or are you doing things that are
going to keep you healthy you know like
and those are very interesting nuances
that I don't think are being broken down
just yet in health wellness and Beauty I
would agree I would agree including I'll
give you another one Cosmetics that are
clean
versus not right right those are like
new conversations we're having but to
your point are you are we as parents
teaching our children your validation to
the world your self-esteem should be re
wrapped up in how you look or on who you
are and I think they come in all shapes
and sizes and I think it's dangerous to
be black and white right because you
know look I think beauty is like an
important part of the world we like
Marvel at like sunsets and we like we
like when it's nice outside like we
shouldn't demonize some things I don't
think it's a trivial thing I don't think
it's not important but I think balance
and all this I think a lot about the
color purple these days so as America
has really locked into a war amongst red
and blue politically I know the way we
get out of this is by everyone falling
in love with purple
and I think everyone's digging in too
deep
people are even changing their minds on
things just to fit a red or blue
and so I think this issue fits similarly
which is like we shouldn't demonize
people that want to look good I think it
matters quite a bit
but I but we can't make it the thing
they're completely known for and to the
point of this combo when are we going to
start holding people up on a pedestal
that are the nicest yeah not the richest
or the prettiest correct and I think we
have the potential to do that totally I
would I mean I really hope so I think as
a society we do have the potential to do
that too well I think it happens in
Pockets right you and I have a lot of
different like you probably have three
four five two six meaningful friend
groups in my world I would argue that
most of my friend groups that really are
my actual friends are actually quietly
built on that because you know you just
want to be with people that are nice of
course you know or common interests
right okay Switching gears a little bit
but it's kind of on the same I mean it's
all it all works into itself as someone
who recently pivoted in their business
I'd close the doors on each Being Fit
how do you how did that feel you know
what it honestly like the weight was
lifted good and how long did you sit on
it
I mean I've been sitting on it for about
two 15 months yeah two years I always
think people like especially when you're
like any any like anybody who's this is
so important everyone who's listening
having the strength to close something
when you are so out in front of it is
one of the most courageous acts a human
can do
which is why it always takes time to do
it yeah and I was I was
really nervous it makes sense I was
really really nervous but ultimately
like it just the business model didn't
make sense I don't have you know I would
have to hire three more people I don't
have that salary income I don't have you
know I'm not raising money for it it
doesn't make any money like it ran its
course it ran its course and
anyway so what would you I feel like
you're the type of person who
takes pivots and strides like you well
it goes back to what we were talking
about exactly you know to your point
rightfully so when because I know enough
about you you're thinking from a B to C
and A B2B perspective what is this going
to look like because that's the right
thing to do
your young ambitious woman with lots of
goals and tons of stuff in front of you
and you are actually being thoughtful by
saying hey this is something I'm very
associated with
people are going to have judgment on
this
um what is this going to mean and to
your point
what why I'm like really excited you
brought this up and what I'm hoping
people get out of this is
even if you and this is not your case
because you have too many other things
that you're winning on but let's say for
everyone at home right now even if the
one thing that you're known for the only
thing that's good
seemingly on paper is a win for you in
your career you're not multi-dimensional
like you're just the ice cream man you
have four ice cream shops that's what
you're known for like that's it and
you're at a point where it's not going
well like maybe somebody's come in and
innovated and is beating you up and
you're underwater and now you're taking
your savings to keep up the business
these are real talks yeah
even for that person if something's not
right
it's only causing an emotional cancer
inside of you the anxiety the sleepless
nights the passive aggressive ways
you're acting with the people around you
because you're not happy
it's just a weight and the reality is is
even with all the judgment
you've got to get into a place and
saying look
here's the thing that works for me when
I do it hey I'm gonna have to take this
l
it's really not fun I don't want to
there's going to be a news cycle
and everybody has a new cycle some
people only have four relatives that are
part of the new cycle other people have
100 million followers
from Beyonce to Ricky Thompson who has
his mom is the new cycle that's the only
person even knows he's an introvert and
a Hermit and the only person even knows
who he is and what he's doing is his mom
everyone has a new cycle where people
are gonna have judgment people are going
to have to say what they say but
actually I'm going to give you an
interesting answer to this Hannah as
I've been setting up the answer okay the
answer to the question is humility
um
the reason I can deal with it in stride
is because I always after I think it all
the way through go to this final place
gives a [__] the [__] I'm doing
yeah you see where this goes it's really
neat I go through all the things that I
was talking about but where do I end up
to why I get to a good place it's
humility at the end of the day for all
the good things that are going for me in
entrepreneur land when not if when I
have entrepreneurial failures in the
future what will allow me to do it and
make me take it in stride is realizing
that I don't mean that much in the world
at the end of the day
that that cool there'll be 24 hours on
Twitter where people like see Gary
you're not as good as you thought you
were maybe there's a couple people that
were disappointed internally of like man
how did he not pull off like he should
have been good at selling footballs like
he likes football like why did that not
work
and what really always gets me there is
like humility I think humility is an
incredibly important part of the
ingredients that an alpha an ambitious a
striver needs to have
I ultimately think like
yeah there'll be some judgment but like
they'll move on to the next thing the
next day totally like in a year are
people really going to be talking about
it's not really I'm gonna move on to and
by the way I also have a lot of
compassion for people that are in the
business of gossip and tearing people
down
totally like like what a miserable life
reality to be in where you're spending
all your time carrying other people's
you know
reality sound like honestly I you know
as long as you gave it your best effort
then I admire people that take those
chances
yeah you're gonna get buffed you're not
going to do any colors no I've been very
bullish on male makeup for a long time
yeah yeah it's a huge category I know I
have video I'm very proud I have a bunch
of videos five six years ago saying next
decade watch this oh if anyone's name
and who's trying to create a male color
Cosmetic Company this is your angel
investor right here 100
um okay mocktails oh yeah huge huge huge
um okay last question really before our
quick fire around because you're almost
done
um
last night I was at this dinner and this
is emotional intelligence coach was you
know having this amazing conversation
and she mentioned something about like
you know how we're always just like
looking to talk about or engage in
personal growth yes she was kind of
saying that
she knows who she is and she's 47 years
old and she doesn't want to keep growing
but that she wants to keep evolving
and that those are two different things
do you know what I hear when I hear that
tell me
and I'm 47 so that makes me excited I'm
so in love with this person without
knowing them you know what she's saying
I don't want to judge myself
the the Nuance of evolving versus growth
is when you are in this game of growth
if you watch the people that are most
obsessed with it they're over judging
themselves
they're subtly beating themselves up
like I need to be better I have to be I
got to be better right I'm not good at
this I think what she's saying quick hot
take on hearing that because it really
hit me in my chest because I'm very
similar
is I don't want to beat myself up
I think the Reason by the way back to
the last thing that so many people are
judging everyone else is because it
starts at home right they're judging
themselves right and the way they're
dealing with that pain because they keep
hitting themselves up is they deploy it
to others so you know when I hear that
that makes sense to me I think we've got
to find a way to be less judgmental on
ourselves but to her point you always
want to evolve right but I understand I
I think I understand where she's going
yeah it was interesting because she was
when she first started talking about
like kind of getting over this idea of
constant growth I was kind of like
saying to myself well but there's so
many things that I want to accomplish
and do and then she moved into this it's
not about like you can still evolve
within yourself but the constant idea
that you're not satisfied that with
yourself is and I found it just like
really beautiful I thought you were
gonna like that so that's what I wanted
well it's funny you just made me think
of something that really hit my team the
other day we're on this journey at this
marketing firm and it's like really like
going to be a thing like we genuinely
like are gonna are starting to and when
it's all said and done have changed the
way people think about my Marketing in
the world which is really cool
but there's so much pushback like people
still believe a television commercial is
more important than a single Tick Tock
and I really don't think that
the that the Ocean Spray Tick Tock will
sell more Ocean Spray which it did than
any commercial which is true
so we're at this very philosophical
meeting where the team is talking about
the frustrations of getting the world on
board
and I said something that's just very
real to me that touches on what you just
said I looked at them all and I said
we've already won
and it's funny when you just said what
you said about what she was saying
I feel like that is another big
quote-unquote secret to why things have
worked for me similar to what I said
earlier about not being attached to the
validation of the success
when I tell you the most emotional
professional day of my career to this
day is still the first full day of work
at my dad's store
May
20 something
1998. coming up on an anniversary yeah
1998 is still the most significant day
of my life because somewhere around
fourth grade I dreamed for the day where
I could work
full time
and I remember like yesterday driving
right over there over those Hills from
Huntington County New Jersey to my dad's
store for 40 minutes
and I remember literally saying to
myself
there'll never be a better day than this
because this is the starting point of
what I've always wanted to do
and and basically I was saying to myself
I had one already regardless of what's
about to happen over these next 50 years
just playing means I've won and so like
what you know especially since Kobe's
death which I think really was just such
a cultural and especially because I'm
very
tied into being competitive and I just
like a lot of the way he moved
he's one of the people that's just very
clear for him it was like he'd won the
day his career started like the game
itself and that's how entrepreneurship
is for me the game itself is the win
nothing else and I was telling team we'd
already won we're like and it was funny
to see how well that landed with
everyone and like gave them some sort of
weird peace of mind
and I think that's what I want for every
individual like when you go and do the
thing you want to do regardless of the
money or the notoriety if you are
passionate about planting and you've
started a micro planting farming flour
vegetable business if it like the amount
of people that have a business like that
that does 180 000 a year in sales and
they take home sixty seven thousand and
they live on that 67 000 and are happy
as [__] it's those people and sometimes
they look like Kobe and it's financially
and culturally satisfying it just
happened to be that for him but back to
like all the hidden people that we don't
talk about a dentist that's all he ever
wanted like he's pumped I want that
that's why the first book I ever wrote
was based on that but people keep
thinking it's foofy foofy silly stuff
and I keep saying that the internet has
made it very real right
sick okay well this is an amazing chat
we're just gonna do a quick fire round
so like the first answer that comes to
you yeah we'll just have like five quick
questions let's do it great what's your
non-negotiable in the morning
um to check my phone to make sure
there's no fires
mine is to not check my phone yeah and
again I want to stay here because these
value people that's what's so cool about
the world I would argue for most people
it's not to check their phone right but
for me I love being accountable and
responsible to my world and I know that
that gives me peace of mind look on the
phone make sure that no one's had a
horrific event that the Singapore office
didn't have a fire like it'd be grossly
negligible for me based on what I the
BET I've made for me not to look and a
quick look actually then makes me calm
by the way there's plenty of times where
there's some bad stuff like we lost a
big client that would seemingly be bad
that's not bad for me that's micro bad I
just have to check it because I'm the
last line of defense right
okay okay how do you take your coffee
with a lot of cream so I'm not a coffee
purist like I am a wine purist I like
the sensation of the mouth feel of cream
oh wow okay for me the pistachio latte
yummy
do you have a night
what would you pick cold plunge massage
or sauna
that's a good one I would go with sauna
I think I would too I really think well
in that environment which I enjoy
to visit one place in the world right
now where bless you go
um
the bless you Dustin the there is a like
Thousand Mile garage sale that happens
in August of every year it goes from
like Tennessee to like and I like I've
been dying to go because I love garage
selling is like genuinely a hobby of
mine so I would go to like a small town
in Tennessee to their garage sale
I really wasn't expecting
that goes back to the way this all
started self-awareness yeah I don't get
as much enjoyment at a three-star
Michelin in France even though that's
rad because I love food and wine uh I'm
on in Utah like what a place like you
can really rest the Jets game like one
of my favorite places to go Madison
Square Garden the plant like these are
great Joys but there's something super
weird for me personally
about going to a garage sale that is
like so calming and fun and I love it I
would probably go to the Grand Canyon
I've never been and I feel like where I
am in my life I could use some expansive
I love that yeah okay is this the last
one yes okay have you ever tried a diet
fad if so which one I haven't I um
what's really interesting though is a
diet fad even though I don't think it's
a fad I think it's probably really real
is something I've done pretty much my
whole life I
fast often and I don't mean the modern
one that's like 18 hours and this that
like I mean like 30 40 like I really
love the feeling of a fast and at this
point in my life I'm fasting almost once
a week and I mean from dinner on a
Monday at nine until Wednesday dinner so
48 hours I I am having water and I'm
having again not a not a considered
modern fast because I am having a coffee
at times and sometimes cream which I I
know disqualifies it from what people
consider fasting but I do not put a
single piece of food in my body for 48
hours probably every week
you like that one that was mind-blowing
wow why does she see it like a lot yeah
that's actually feels good weirdly good
for yourselves because people do do
these water fast once a week and they
their cells are generated at a very
interesting rate
um I've tried them all so I can't can't
tell you but I don't do anything now
besides thank you so much thank you
and that's what we have for you
thank you so much thank you for having
me
[Music]